andreas Laing is on the way to his
current workplace today I'll be
selecting video sequences from my last
trip to Cameroon and preparing them for
processing and editing to be used later
in the video installation at the
exhibition the photographer and video
artists current studio is under the roof
of the German Foreign Office it
commissioned long to travel to Cameroon
and follow the trail of Germany's
colonial history as well as that of his
own family his great-grandfather was a
soldier in the German colonial
protection force his research unearthed
photos finding them was really a stroke
of luck there was his name in his rank
written underneath I've never really
known what rank he had it said sergeant
couplet on our team hippopotamus lungs
photos depict remnants of the colonial
era they're snapshots such as this
cabinet makers workshop with colonial
style furniture spawned off it was
already there and we just had to
encounter each other with the photo and
I the colonial era is still present for
the people there as well
such as for this man from the village of
banana the name was given to the
settlement by the Germans
I know that's it see that explains that
on the one hand there were certainly
even friendships but on the other hand
that there were beatings there was often
violence and despotism in the Foreign
Office archives lung found a contract in
which Germany and France agreed on new
borders for Cameroon and Congo that was
an imperialist action the population had
to just cope with it or not or there
were rebellions for Andrea's lung this
part of Germany's history has not yet
been processed he believes his work will
spark uncomfortable but necessary
questions about the country's colonial
past